so how did you were you at the same time
then auditioning for TV stuff or how did
you even come into the late night orbit
the late night orbit kind of came into
the theater you know like the theater at
that time really just sort of became
like where people yeah the breeding
ground where the casting people yeah
because they started using the original
UCB for for sure we used them in
sketches starting right when they moved
there in like 95 late 95 early 96. and
so then it was like oh we just kept
going there to look for you know more
performers yeah and it was uh so I think
that's that so that was it I I had you
know I was I don't even think I had a
manager at the time I was like trying to
find managers and so you know all the
auditions that I would go to would be
those kind of the weird ones you see in
like old movies you know where it's like
you and 20 people just showing up and
everybody's holding their headshots and
you know this guy wants me to be
shirtless for this one
[Laughter]
you're in this comedy bit that aired in
2000 and it was just
it just became a big hit and it kind of
lived on in Conan lore for many years I
mean really people still talk about that
and that's why we want to talk to you
it's called dudes a plenty and it it was
basically dudes with a z yes plenty with
an i that's right right take that shirt
off and
you know is it the height of boy bands
so well and also the height of uh people
making boys yeah it's like it was this
idea group together and we're gonna make
them right yeah Simon Cowell Making the
Band cranking them out if Daddy made a
band Making the Band it was a big show
yeah and it was all people are you're
right profiling kind of the The Maniacs
it was usually you know like one man who
managed and created Five bands
simultaneously yeah so it was a perfect
scenario for Conan to play The Puppet
Master yes and it was all about his
journey creating this one his vision
yeah so it was exactly that a parody of
these behind the scenes boy band shows
and you were one of the the lucky five
to be one of dudes of Plenty so yeah
they came to me and um uh
Celia yeah yes uh see the booker yeah
she um
it was it was uh Andy Blitz he was a
writer wrote the wrote dudes a plenty
and I I don't even know this might have
been before people were texting so this
all might have been phone calls where I
think he like called and was like
can you can you like sing and dance and
I was like yeah and then and could you
yeah okay
I mean not professionally like that and
also you know who knows maybe not I was
overly confident at the time something I
was like yeah
a lot of actors it's like can you
horseback ride and you're like yeah of
course
they're really answering the question
will you do this yeah
um no but I could at the time for sure I
could definitely sing and dance um I
could still sing and dance you look
check this out okay oh my God look at
this dance we'll insert that later yeah
and here's my singing
oh wow that was yeah so um
[Laughter]
you can't go oh my God Celia called me
same questions could you come in and you
know just kind of come in for like an
audition you know uh and so I went in
to an audition and it was pretty much I
think just an audition to see if I could
physically like dance and look like I
could dance with real dancers and sing a
little bit
and uh and I guess I hit that bar enough
to be able to go in and so then it was
like me and these other Broadway guys oh
they were Broadway yeah they were like
all Broadway did really sound good
together those guys were like better
than it needed to be yeah when I when I
did arrive I was like waiting to see you
know other other UCB I was like oh
there'll be some other UCB people who
could pass the dancers and there were no
others it was just these other actual
singers and dancers yeah wow well I
guess they'd ever and they also have
that certain boy band look yes you know
because there are a lot of there's some
pretty faces did you have to take off
your shirt for the audition that was a
question I had
I think I had to take but then you know
what though you know I did I do remember
the tank top so you know I am in a tank
top yeah and this is something I I found
out years later uh somebody who knew me
back then was like no you were always a
shirt off kind of guy and I was like
what's that mean and they're like like
when you'd go out and you'd be out doing
stuff you would like you'd take your
shirt off oh and I was so that's because
like making fun of some guy I saw
walking on the street oh yeah yeah and
they were like what are you talking
about that's what you used to do and so
maybe she maybe she had already seen me
with my shirt
so how did they prepare you for what the
remote was going to be because remotes
are different from being in a sketch
where there's probably more improv
involved I mean it was a little bit of a
process you know because this was like
uh they did really did that song right
yeah so like we came in we had rehearsal
for just the song it was a two-parter
you taped a hole behind the scenes part
with Conan yeah but then the big payoff
once that was all edited and assembled
you and dudes of Plenty appeared like
Conan we did a library
yeah dude and it was amazing it was
incredibly well produced yeah so it was
a live element too which was another it
was a live element I mean yeah I mean it
was like performing on uh the a late
night show and so uh it was uh very
exciting there was just a couple of
rehearsals I think it was really just we
had a rehearsal for the song we had a
rehearsal for the dancing moves and then
the day of we kind of had a rehearsal
with all those things together we the
song was pre-recorded so we had like a a
session where we went in and just
recorded our parts for the song yeah but
it was your voices it was all about
voices and we do sing you do we are
singing on the in the thing but it's
just we had to have the actual track to
back us up and then uh as most boy bands
do most points do yeah is that song
online like is on it is
on the actual song oh I don't know I
don't know who owns that song could it
be a ringtone maybe
maybe it's a girls five other thing
where it is my mom's ringtone yeah I'm
not lying yeah she somehow got it I
saved as a ringtone I think somebody
somebody made it for him
yeah so did you tell people when you
book to this like you gotta watch this
night or were you like let me watch it
first and then I'll tell people oh no I
only told people I mean yeah you know
again this is like before like you're I
wasn't able to like text all the people
or call all the people I know so I think
I just called my mom
yeah yeah exactly I put it on my MySpace
page and then we had and then we had the
day where we shot the actual right the
sketch that you know that that they saw
that was super fun that was a blast oh
yeah so were you nervous in that you
were meeting Conan you were working with
these other people four actors who came
from Broadway were you just kind of like
ah I'm ready for this or it was part of
you kind of like oh this is I don't
screw it up yeah I think I definitely
thought I think I remember being like
don't screw this up
um you know it was but because it was
these other guys from
Broadway and I was had been doing a lot
of stuff at UCB and you know Conan uh is
fits in very well in that world of
Comedy you know as you know playing you
know this crazy guy who's trying to put
the band together right yeah it felt a
little bit easier for me because it was
like a group of guys so I don't it's not
all on me to like hold it together right
and I also probably had done more things
similar to what we were doing than the
rest of them I felt so I was like well
I'll just do what I've been doing and
you know remember your training yeah
you're an athlete I'm an act leader
don't get a brown bag foul